what's up
guys bang bang lunch money time
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
polina marinova pompliano
or p-i-m-p you all know what it is don't
forget that lunch money is now sponsored
by
blockfi you can earn up to 8.6 apy
in an interest-bearing account yesterday
i got my interest
payment i hope you did too if you didn't
go sign up for block five
block five dot com slash pomp p-o-m-p
block five dot com slash pomp and you
can get an interest
bearing account that earns you up to
eight point six percent apy
i thought that was the code i had
something to do with lunch money but um
i'm wrong they actually go to the same
place oh no problem great
i learned that yesterday so why'd you
switch it from lunch money to pomp
sounds a little
egotistical don't we think no it's
easier to remember
no it's not people will watch lunch
money lunch money is easier to remember
yeah but see palm they might confuse
pomp with pimp but pomp
and pole all right what's going on
the global economy is not looking great
um the ceo of deutsche bank said the
global economy will not return to
pre-corona
virus levels for a long time business
activity in the eurozone dropped sharply
in the wake of the strict lockdown
measures opposed in march but have
somewhat rebounded in recent months
following the easing of certain
restrictions
does he say how long nope no so much
longer
than we assumed today he said okay i
mean look
i don't know why this is newsworthy
whenever people say things like oh it's
gonna take much longer than we thought
no but but what do we think about like
the global
situation not just in the us like how
long do we think the global economy will
recover well it's the same thing
everywhere
right in terms of everyone went into
lockdown you literally shut down
economies
and so they don't you you don't just get
it's not like a light switch you can't
just
turn the economy on shut it off turn it
on shut it off turn it on shut it off
that's not how economies work so if you
think of just an individual business
regardless of what country they're in
what currency they use
what language they speak any of that
stuff you cannot run a business
every day be working to build that
business all of a sudden somebody says
stop you literally have to send
everybody home
in many cases fire them furlough them
whatever and then all of a sudden
somebody says okay turn your business
back on
like it doesn't work that way he didn't
offer though he said
the pre-crisis level will be difficult
to reach it will take a long time
this is not going to happen this year
and not next year either so we're
looking at
maybe 2022. yeah and i also think the
other piece that people forget is like
they think of just like the individual
employee
so we sent all of our employees home
let's get our employees back like
that's pretty quote-unquote easy in the
sense of you can go
call them whatever but also they may
have taken other jobs unemployment may
be paying them more like
there's complexity to just getting your
employees you might not have the money
to hire them all back
all of that but the the more complex
thing is what if your supply chain has
been shut down so if you're a restaurant
you need to get food now you got to call
back up your supplier and say hey
i need this food they say great we'll
get it to you in three weeks right or
they say hey you know what we can't
actually
get it because we're having trouble get
sourcing it from x location
and part of the global supply chain so
it's just when you break all this stuff
to build it back in a uh efficient
manner it takes a lot
a long time and so i think that that and
it's not weeks right i mean it is
literally going to be
years i'm really mad at the politicians
yeah i don't think they should be making
the decisions i think i should
naval had a great tweet the other day or
i think it was yesterday he said
we should put the politicians and the
journalists
on unemployment and the lockdowns will
end immediately
think about that right what's next
man okay then so
today in new york city gyms
are allowed to reopen at i think at a 25
capacity but the owner of the new york
sports club chain said it may need to
file for bankruptcy in the near future
because so many it's been
everything's been shut for so long um
so yeah i mean i don't know what's going
to happen also my question
oh god no go no go my question was going
to be
to you governor cuomo how does it make
sense to open gyms before indoor dining
indoor dining people are separated on
tables you can be in your own little pod
gyms you're touching you're sweating
you're moving around people i don't like
it
i mean look there's definitely uh um
nonsense there's another word i want to
use but i'm not going to use it but
there's a lot of nonsense that's going
on right now
in terms of picking favorites and
industries you know the gyms get open
but the restaurants you can only have
people's casinos are up next apparently
yeah i mean look it's all it's all
nonsense right and then you look at like
the cdc report
and the cdc report that came out said it
was like 94 96
of people uh who have died i'm gonna put
it in air quotes
uh had pre-existing conditions right and
so again when you get down into this
it just goes back to the data is
unreliable we're making
bad decisions because we're using bad
data and we need to make sure that the
data is more accurate
nobody seems to be interested in that
that is not part of the conversation
literally today i saw on cnn and that
they have a
scoreboard it's like a scoreboard like
like they're they're uh
celebrating or cheering on the numbers
going higher literally when you go watch
the news right now there is a scoreboard
that takes over the right side of the
screen
i think that depending on where you fall
in the political spectrum you have a
talk track and you have a version of
reality that you
believe to be true and it's very hard
when
two sides of the country are living in
different realities but but that's my
point this isn't a political thing
people are trying to make it political
but this is not political i don't align
with either political party this is a
seeker of truth
perspective the data is bad you can't
make good decisions whether you're a
republican democrat green you're data
better
well the first thing you have to do is
you have to get testing and the second
thing you have to do is you have to
change the incentive structure
right now we are incentivizing
healthcare officials
to give us bad data that's been my
problem the entire time
we literally said to the hospitals we
said if you mark somebody as a covid
death
we will pay you money so of course
they're going to mark people
right and they're going to mark people
who didn't die but they can't just mark
people and lie
there's example after example after
example remember the story in the guy in
florida a guy died in a motorcycle
accident
a motorcycle accident and he was marked
as a coveted death
because they get paid money so i don't
want to go deep down in the rabbit hole
we got to get better data
and part of this plan i think is uh
things like
gyms the whole reason why new york
sports club is saying that they may go
out of business
is because they have debt and they don't
have enough cash on hand this isn't
nothing like oh we don't want to pay
or uh whatever if they literally don't
have enough cash flow
to have the cash in the bank to be able
to pay off the loan when it comes due in
november
and so you have to remember that there's
not only supply chain complexities here
there's also the way that businesses are
financed if there's any level of debt
when you shut off the revenue stream
they don't have the cash to pay back and
there could be a chain reaction to a
capital markets as well
in march uh i spent some time
talking to small business owners uh all
over the country
to see how they were handling it this
was just still in march like weeks after
uh the stay at home orders were put in
place and i
reached out to them again this week and
basically a lot of them said uh when the
what does it call the ppe ppp loans
uh when all of that expires in october
some of them are going to shut
permanently so if anyone wants a laugh
if you live anywhere else in the world
other than in new york city right now
i'm going to give you the funniest thing
i've heard so far the mayor of new york
said he's not he's not allowing
restaurants to let people indoors
until there's a vaccine let me just let
me let you guys think about that for a
second
restaurants in new york city will not be
allowed to let people inside
until there is a vaccine which first
problem is they
there's no guarantee that there's going
to be a vaccine the second problem is
that
that could take 18 to 24 months
or more so somehow we went from flatten
the curve
to now we have to prevent every single
death and there has to be a vaccine in
order to open the economy
these people are insane
next topic okay um
okay so tick tock i don't know really
what's going on it says a deal for tick
tocks u.s businesses facing new hurdles
as the u.s deadline for sale approaches
an announcement of a deal was expected
but basically on friday chinese
officials had introduced new
restrictions on technology experts
that could require chinese approval for
tick tock to sell its
algorithm which is part of the which is
the core value of the app
reminder the us and china they're at war
they're engaged in an economic war
they're engaged in a technology war
they're engaged in every single form of
combat other than a violent combat does
that mean that
you know how tick tock was like china we
don't report to china we don't talk to
china but now china's like
we want to know we want to be involved
in the process of the
algorithm being sold off well no i mean
look they're essentially planned economy
which means that the
government has a lot of say over things
there's a chinese company that owns this
product
and they're basically saying you can't
export your technology without our
approval
okay again that's their right that's the
country they live in that's the
leadership decision
whatever but it just goes to show that
they are playing different rules
and by the way in the u.s we have
similar types of rules right there's
certain things like u.s companies can't
do business with huawei
so is it like national security well i
don't know if they went that far as to
say that
uh but there's definitely this
ratcheting up between the united states
and china
and they are engaged in this competition
war may be a
an aggressive uh way to describe
competition
but that competition is on the economic
side it's on the social side
it is on the uh democratic ideal side
and now it's on the technology front and
we are seeing two countries
manipulate and use the corporations
within their borders
as tools in this like geopolitical
showdown
good for tick tock us ceo who resigned
he was like
peace out i did not sign up to be a pawn
in your big ass game
all right ready yes okay michael jordan
what up shares of draftkings jumped 13
in pre-market trading after the company
said michael jordan
is joining the betting company as a
special adviser to the board of
directors
first of all do we think michael jordan
giving his
past should be advising a betting
company
michael jordan is the best person in the
world to be ready to help them with some
little betting
for those that don't know michael jordan
is the best player ever to live
i don't care what you say don't leave
any comments tell me that lebron or
kobe's better
scottie pippen no michael jordan's the
best player to ever play the game of
basketball
but on top of that he has a very
very deep uh history
of gambling and so this is a way for
people to gamble
he enjoys doing it that's fine he
understands sports he understands
gambling
makes a ton of sense go ahead why do you
think so do you think
like what's what's the benefit for him
well he got a bunch of money no equity
yeah he probably got a bunch of equity
uh and um he may have even invested
alongside it i mean look you can
remember draftkings went public through
a spac
that spak uh posts back uh kind of
public maneuver
uh i think it went from like three
billion dollars to a 13 billion dollar
market cap
so anytime that you see this uh where
they're basically building value right
there
they're attracting uh successful
entrepreneurs did you know that jordan
is the owner of the charlotte hornets
franchise yeah have you been living
under a rock
you don't even know where the charlotte
hornets in charlotte north carolina okay
gray what sport do they play
basketball yeah they do what colors are
they blue no
well kind of you're not uh baby blue uh
no it's turquoise but that's fine
it's baby do you know who mugsy bogues
is yes
he's small yeah a little short guy yeah
he used to play there oh i remember this
was in a lunch money episode from like
1992. okay so michael jordan by the way
is a billionaire for those that don't
know
go ahead okay really is he really a
billionaire yeah
and michael yeah killing it all right
priscilla chan and mark zuckerberg are
putting up
putting up 300 million to promote safe
and reliable voting in states and
localities amid the pandemic
so they're basically donating their
money to election
infrastructure what do you think um
i think that's good i mean it's very
focused it's very
um specific it's not just like i'm going
to donate it to a political party even
though they probably are
um yeah my uh when i worked there
we launched voting we launched a product
uh that did voter registration so
basically there was a thing in the news
feed
that uh allowed you to register to vote
uh it was respectful for a lot of people
registering to vote in countries where
we launched it while it was clear
this is very similar in that i don't
care how you vote yeah
but a very important part of a
democratic nation is to have
uh secure well-trained efficient
and trusted legitimate
voting infrastructure uh and so things
are going to stuff like staffing
training equipment etc
people will try to politicize something
like this but i think this is the most
non-political way
i think that's great to to try to ensure
that people can go and vote
yeah it's great it's good that's part of
being a democracy
all right all right so i don't even want
to tell you because you'll be like i
told you but you didn't tell me
because they didn't okay so do you
remember a few days ago when i one of
the topics on lunch money was mcdonald's
and the woman was lying i don't know if
she was like but the woman said that
from like 1996 or something she put a
mcdonald like a burger and fries from
mcdonald's in a closet
it has been perfectly preserved okay so
out of nowhere without being prompted
mcdonald's came out with a statement
saying that its burgers do decompose
busting this myth um
so you know there's there's been a myth
that it's burgers do not rot
um saying it's food but but it said it's
food would decompose
in the right environment that's a little
tricky
it's almost like i knew i could sniff
out
wait a second though wait a second
without sufficient moisture
either in the food itself or the
environment bacteria and mold may not
grow
and therefore decomposition is unlikely
so i bet you it wasn't
damp in her closet was she doing a
science experiment where she's got it
locked in a moisture free box
yeah is that what really that's what
that's what she she opened a shoe box
in 1996 yeah but there's no moisture in
there
a shoe box is not like air sealed i know
but there's no moisture have you ever
put anything in
in a closet and seen what happens when
you leave it there for a little bit yeah
my shoes
and what happens i don't know sometimes
like they get all like
um oh interesting no like like like uh
what is it called like harder or not
moist moisture
okay we're not gonna do a science
experiment today but like i said this is
all nonsense
yeah so look closely the burgers you're
seeing are likely dried out and
dehydrated mcdonald's said that happens
to my shoes
and they're saying their burgers were
100 beef with no fillers or
preservatives
should we get some mcdonald's today no
let's go what's the next thing that's
it that's it and i have a joke all right
what's your joke
all right people are shocked when they
find out
i'm a terrible electrician
not even i i can see it right here
guys yesterday anthony called lake como
like cuomo
i did do that on a call with somebody
who who like
basically lives in italy yeah i was i
was telling them that we went to
lake como and uh instead of lake cuomo
and then i just heard a little bird
chirping in the background giggling to
herself
i was dying i was like you know you've
been reading the news too much when
yeah exactly all right anything left for
the people i like the people be kind to
your friends by the way
i saw your comments i heard that you
didn't like the brad pitt
thing but i did but i understand so we
will not be including
celebrity gossip any longer but if you
want me just call me
no celebrity guys i don't have time for
anything is garbage i'm here to talk
about the news
and let's move on all right guys that's
it for lunch monday today while while
she's trying to get rich for us let's
try to get our lunch money right we'll
see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends